I don't think that you can paint
everyone in Gaza suffering at the hands
of Israel as people who are aspired to
join Hamas but I will say that the
people in Hamas certainly have suffered
at the hands of Israel I'm sure the vast
majority have lost paramilitary group
it's a paramilitary group um it's sure
it's a terrorist group but again what
are they going to do outside of
terrorism you know this is what happens
right this is
unfortunately uh you know and it's not
doesn't condone it it doesn't excuse it
it doesn't justify it what it says is
contextually when people feel like they
have zero hope and they've seen their
family and friends murdered they Embrace
these pathologies this isn't new right
it doesn't mean that all terrorism comes
from that and it doesn't mean that all
malice or evil in the world comes from
that either there are people that do bad
things for the sake of doing bad things
there are people that want control over
other people for the sake of it there
are people that I'm sure want to
ethnically cleanse Israel uh IM material
of what Israel does I'm I'm sure that
those people do exist I know they exist
and I've I've heard them but in this
particular situation it does feel like
there has to be a way to give
Palestinians autonomy and rights and
prevent decades more of this and cycles
of violence and I don't think Hamas is a
terrorist group yeah and is that well
they engage in terrorism right I mean
it's a terrorist thing does that mean
it's such an arbitrary term I want to be
clear about what we're talking about
could say that Israel is engaging in it
too anybody who's engaging in the type
of stuff that we're doing but I I think
when you go to Music Festival
indiscriminately killing people that
seems to be terrorism right if you
kidnap children that seems to be
terrorism right I mean it doesn't now
you might say they don't have uh the
military to engage like but when you're
hitting soft civilian targets as
Israel's done so I'm not absolving them
to me that's kind of the definition of
terrorism it's like so s civilian now
that that means like there's a lot of
armies that you could say but I wouldn't
say Hamas is not a terrorist group
because their
aims you know seem to be to inflict
Terror on the Israeli population and the
same way that Israel in the way that is
behaving now seems to inflict Terror on
so I I don't I don't want to absolve one
group and say that the other group
because they both seem to want to do the
same thing you know I mean Israel is
doing it with a military but that
doesn't mean that it's not terrorism
right and I mean that might mean that
all war is Terrorism but I wouldn't want
to absolve Hamas I don't know what Hamas
wants for Gaza that's part of the hard
thing right I don't know what Hamas I
know that they've taken a lot of money
from Qatar I don't know what they've
done with it and I don't know if they
have the best interest of people in Gaza
at heart I don't know that that I know
that they want uh the Israeli occupation
to end but I don't know enough about
them to know what exactly are they good
at governing Gaza are they a legitimate
gu because it seems like they're not
good at
that well it's hard to govern a
population that's under blockade right
don't allow clean water I have no idea I
mean that's the thing is you look at the
world and you look at places like Egypt
and and other places in the Middle East
and it's a lot of repression and it's
like what would this region look like
without us interference I don't know
there a ton of oil wealth there's a ton
of money t of oil wealth and that that
strikes at the heart of why it's such an
important Colonial Outpost for the US I
don't know if you just saw this this
clip from RFK Junior actually just
explicitly laying be the utility of
Israel for the US Empire I've never
actually seen someone I've seen I think
that's an open seat people know that
people know it people know it yeah for
sure but but so I think that like also
debunks the whole like why do you care
about Israel so much it's like I it's
it's the US yeah Outpost in the is any
of that repression also religious is any
of that religious where you go this is
something that is just inherently based
in religion but what has allowed the
religious rep repression to flourish
it's it's stimming and subjugating
populations for sure and a lot of policy
Pockets where religious fundamentalism
has has but then you have countries like
Saudi Arabia that are incredibly wealthy
and Incredibly powerful and who is
preventing any sort of sanctions or
International laws Saud Arab NBS is kind
of opening that Society up now right
little by little I don't think so seems
to be that's a PR campign well they've
they've certainly made a lot of uh
advancements I mean you know whether
it's enough advancements allowing women
to drive finally in some are and I
disagree with that but they're doing
that and I'm not even huge on them
voting I said go to the arys tour I
don't I don't you know my whole thing
with women is keep your [__] away from
me and don't vote but and I but I love
them in every other capacity but my my
whole thing is I Tred you know what no
but I I I'm saying that there is there
does seem to be like whether it's
fundamentalist Christianity or
fundamentalist Islam or fundamentalist
Judaism fundamentalist religion is a
problem too that removed from politics
removed from the concerns there does
seem to be in all cultures uh a a need
to
enslave People based on religion that is
like if if we got rid of all us Empire
things would none of that exist because
it existed before the US Empire this
idea that religion would just dictate
and there would be certain people that
would like you know rise to the top of
societies by promise and we see it in
America right we see it right now with
Christians going like you know follow me
I represent God and I'm making the laws
based on God so I mean that's been
around forever it's pre us pre a lot of
that so I there is some of that I I
think that America's made a lot of
mistakes we've done a lot of wrong
things but like I don't think it's all
there is this idea that every evil in
the world comes from
colonialism Andor white people which I
don't know I don't subscribe to that I
know that you're you have friends that
do and there's nothing wrong with that
there's nothing wrong with that but to
defend Whitey for a
minute to whitey and colonialism there
was a lot of brown on Brown colonialism
there was a lot of brown on Brown
slavery and there was a lot of religious
fundamentalism going on all over the
place we didn't invent slavery and we
certainly didn't invent colonialism look
my my answer to that is I can only do
what I can do as an American citizen
we're trying to pitch you to the white
supremacist we're trying to get you on
no you know I I totally I totally hear
you and I can't do anything about
religious fundamental about racist
vegetables I'm saying it doesn't help
just get everyone
healthy